can we talk about uh how Cat Williams Oh
the greatest is not only one of the
greatest comedians of all time
incredibly hilarious but he is without a
doubt the greatest marketer in the
history of
Comedy whoa Cat Williams went on one
podcast gu it like sorry went on one
podcast did one interview and sold out
his next tour two or three times over I
bet I would put any amount of money down
that he has a new tour that's either on
sale or coming up and that he is adding
shows left and right cuz after watching
that you're like I just need to I I need
to watch I need to watch more of this
guy is the most entertaining talker
alive yes and is he making [__] up left
and right is he saying some [__] that's
true left right sure but when you mix
truth and madeup what did we learn from
the EP scene it's entertaining it's very
entertaining but I think it's all facts
all facts all facts you think and we
might have discussed this on Pat you
think that Harvey Weinstein said to him
if you let me suck your dick I'll put
you in my movie Yes you think he read
eight books a day from the age of 6 to
10 we saw him run the 440 like we saw
him we saw it well that's different than
reading eight books a day it doesn't
matter you think you think you prove one
you're wrong actually everything is true
got true and if you disprove one thing
everything is false so you never know
what is true and what is false not a
single lawsuit he made mad claims
nobody's suing him let me ask you this
question
if he's coming to New York are we going
to the show Milli absolutely are are we
the only people thinking this no I'm
bringing no a [__] with me bro come
on front row you forgetting the k bro
that's his he got to spell his name with
three
Cas that's part of the sponsorship D UN
in the sponsorship
deal
okay I'm just saying like what a genius
way if for examp example you already are
not like on the up and up with some of
these people let's say they're your
enemies let's say you're no longer
friends with them you're no longer doing
business with them I think the reason
why again I'm not exactly sure but if
you don't like some of these people
already you don't [__] with them they
don't [__] with you you don't have
anything to lose by saying these things
right you could lose potential future
relationships with them but if you don't
give a [__] about that then you're good
to go MH it's an interesting approach
it's a very hip-hop approach when you
think about it it's like Drake drops the
album there's shots at a bunch of
different people now all of a sudden you
oh is he talking about Kendrick oh is he
talking about jcole oh is he talking
about the whole world's talking about it
now we know the album's coming out maybe
we know the tour is coming out it's it's
a it's a hip-hop blueprint and it's I
think it even hit harder than hip-hop
because comedy has this code where you
guys don't do this to so now he's the
one person that just lightting up and he
didn't even go lightly
he that's why so y' got to stop with
this little code y' got and just start
shooting 202 all y just got to start
shooting Mark just tear him
down I been looking yeah so he's got a
bunch of dates he's doing these Arenas
these first couple are pretty much sold
out which is cool wow I mean you're
crazy if you don't go see what he got to
talk about my question is like how much
of his material did he already say on
the Pod or is he just riffing the whole
time cuz some of the things he had set
up were were like jokes yeah so I'm like
some of this got to be I think
definitely in the beginning like he had
stuff he wanted to say he prepared to
say like that first 30 minutes Shan
didn't talk first 30 minutes he like he
had all these questions and he was just
going in I love how Shan got the cards
bro oh that's awesome and
then what's his face is looking at the
cat's looking at the cards like you
don't even need those my man I got this
I got you sit back relax and enjoy the
show yeah I mean he went on there with
an agenda mhm and the world's was
mesmerized I mean it's all anybody
talked about the same
day Stephen Hawking was having underage
orgies and people were like yeah that's
cool but what is cat saying about
Michael blackon yeah like unbelievable
38 million cover up son
so
going speak on it out every time there's
some Epstein news something big happens
to overshadow it yo speak on it they
paid cat wow they paid
cat yeah wow cover it up so RFK Hawking
rip Billy Billy Copperfield they're like
yo we need to take off the pressure how
do we do it Cat Williams the only one
wow the Messiah yeah I mean it is crazy
40 million views in a week unbelievable
yeah and some and I'm going to the show
when he's in New York I'm going to the
show and some his story is insane like
the whole going to Miami thing like that
whole breakdown I didn't know any of
that and it blew my mind like going to
jail having a kid young all that [__] is
like fascinating yeah I just some of the
shots my only thing is like it is just
like a lot of negativity all right let's
go through the highlights all right I
first off did you see that he went he's
like now going on the road apparently
with like Kevin Hart's X did you see
this n this guy's crazy no no that's
crazy crazy cuz kev's kev's ex does
stand up oh she does yeah his his first
wife I believe does stand up oh and uh
Tory Hart is that her name I think so yo
taking kev's X on the road is crazy bro
nah you can't do that also if you kev's
X you can't do that let that no no no
yes you got to leave the wives out of it
man that's what I'm saying but he
already brought the wives into it he was
talking about like people's wives on the
pot wait pull her up yo come does she
does she the last name though if you
divorced like nah cuz the last name is
it got it got value that's what I'm
saying got
value you got to negotiate that in the
bo yeah like shorty n you keep the house
I want my
name I do know women that keep their
husband's last name even after divorce
just because if they have kids well kids
that's true but also it's just such a
pain in the ass to like you got to go to
the DMV to switch your license your
insurance is like all this [__] and you
a single mom
I'm I don't know exactly if this is true
this is just what's being reported I'm
assuming this is from her Instagram ah
no you can't do this yeah so she's doing
a couple select dates on his new tour n
you can't do this I'm sorry dirty
business over here that's wild Devil's
Advocate why not if she's just a comic
but she's not just a comic she's the ex
of the guy he's taking shots at I mean
uh so there's a couple ways to look at
it one is it a device used by Cat
Williams to annoy or embarrass or
humiliate your ex-husband and if that is
the case are you okay with potentially
aiding and edding the humiliation of
your ex-husband so that you could
further your comedy career cuz I'm sure
if she was like listen he's offering me
these things I I don't want to take it
is there anything else you I bet K would
be like yo come on the road with me you
know what I mean like come I actually I
don't know but yeah man ex-wife on the
was crazy but like you call up one of
your boys yo earthquake please yeah yeah
yeah like going on a road with your
Nemesis someone who's been talking [__]
about you for a minute that you're
openly beefing with that is some hip-hop
[__] though cuz rappers be doing that
that's some gangster ass [__] they get
with their their enemies ex that's the
Jay-Z Nas thing right H but yeah so he
just like goes with everyone fa on love
P Diddy Martin
Lawrence uh not a single person sued
him H it's all fact
facts he went an earthquake it's just
like a lot of I don't know a lot the
thing it's like if you're a comedian you
can't sue when another comedian makes
fun of you or says you got to come back
with jokes Kevin Hart to Tasha K but
Tasha K not a comedian what I'm saying
is another Comics coming at you like
that's why I was annoyed by the Jimmy
Kimmel [__] is like Jimmy Kimmel made
jokes about Aaron Rodgers he joked about
it and then Aaron Rogers made a joke
about Jimmy Kimmel and then Jimmy
Kimmel's like how dare you you're
threatening my livelihood my family I'm
going to sue you and it's like no you
open the can of worms close it with
jokes you could ridicule him with jokes
to the point where he's like I don't
want to mess with this guy this guy a
problem but if you start it you can't be
upset if somebody tries to finish it and
he threw a jab back so I think it's
disappointing you're like first of all
Jimmy like has insanely funny history
like in terms of Comedy like literally
an icon growing up up the earlier stuff
you saw of Jimmy was incredible and then
to see somebody you look up to like that
it's corny yeah like basically going
godam if miles is calling you
corny that that sh hit
different the jokes were easy too they
saying like I'm gonna find him on the
list whatever like I don't know I just
thought that Jimmy really could have
came back at him easy yo Aaron didn't
even say he was going to find him on
list he said he doesn't want it to come
out he's going to pop champagne and you
say yo you're not even you can't pop
champagne this year you're not playing
like it's easy bro I don't know got a
rifle yeah you got a rifle I should hit
him up now Jimmy I guess Jimmy's
argument was was initially making fun of
Aaron was that Aaron was saying that the
aliens was a distraction from the
Epstein list right whether he believes
that or not doesn't really matter once
you call someone a 10 full hat
conspiracy weirdo he has the right to
make fun of you yeah MH yeah yeah like I
I don't know I don't you just want to
see a comedian come back with jokes bro
yeah yeah and we still holding Jimmy to
that level of accountability as comedian
if you just want to be show host maybe
we don't but we see you as comedian does
he still go up I don't think he goes he
owns a comedy club I mean like he's he
doesn't go up then I don't even know if
he was a standup really he was doing
sketch yeah pranks Mano is his show man
is incredible like he has some like
incredible work yeah and I just not a
comic holding him up to Comic standards
I still do because if I found you
hilarious I know what you're capable of
so that's where I hold you it's like
with Eddie Murphy it's like even if he
never gets back on stage again I'm
always going to hold him to the stand
standard of where he was on stage so
it's like and it just can't be legal
action that's the only thing yo legal
it's crazy like who's who's suing for
jokes when you started it yeah yo your
shirt sucks you go yo schz get longer
pants how dare how no son dub Sue out
call a lawyer how dare he sue him
yourself youe
[__] get out of the tunnel the get out
of the tunnel you yeah damn yeah it's
just a I don't know so the whole like
lawsuit thing with cat I don't know if
that's like the move if anyone were to
sue him back it would just look crazy
did anybody handle it the best but I
mean some of the accusations like ke can
I don't know if Cedric still goes up on
stage but if you're basically saying
heyy you're not funny and you steal all
your [__] who's going to Cedric show I
feel like that's something warranted
where it's like no no no I need to clear
that up because that's going to hurt
ticket sales that's going to hurt my
reputation so that's something that if
he said I'm coming back legally I would
respect it that's a good point because
it could actually affect yeah B his his
livelihood yeah but what if you could
come back and clown him in a way that
will reverse that damage that would be
better yeah but if he don't got nobody
writing his comeback then so now you
saying
joke joke he not a comedian you can sue
him sue his don't sue the
show these [__] dring you down
got represent as anyway yeah I'm just
like but I think cat's talented enough
and funny enough that I feel like he
could sell out a tour without having to
be taking people down he's undeniably
one of the most talented and hilarious
comedians ever that being
said this works yeah and sometimes when
something works is hard to change like
there are rappers that are Drake is
talented enough to not mention another
rapper ever once in his in his music
ever but when he does it it works and we
start talking we think about the Rival
we think about the beef so
yeah it's it's one of those tricky
things it's Talent might not mean that
you'll just rely on that or find some
other you know creative way to get the
attention that you want M and uh do you
think this is going to start a trend of
people promoting their shows by [__]
on one another
yeah usually you see it with more
desperate
Comics you know what I mean like cat to
me is not desperate like like you said
he's a [__] genius he he's been doing
this for [__] decades but like
usually you see with Comics that are
like they're struggling for relevance or
they either lost relevance or and it's
not just Comics this pretty much any
industry and or they're really resentful
that other people that they think
they're funnier than have success and
that resentment or bitterness kind of
comes out through that criticism you
know and they're like oh yeah these
people are only on or these people only
doing this because of this thing that
they don't do and but it's rare to see
it somebody at this level to take those
shots unless you in hip-hop and the
highest level is who's taking the shots
right you w even argue that it happens
more at that level you know what I mean
because at the lower level Who you gonna
beef with Drake don't even know your
name yeah so yeah I don't know it's it's
fascinating to see I do think the person
that handled it best was Joe Yo Joe
killed it he's like we love you we talk
about you on the show all the time I'd
love to have you on the show yeah cuz C
was like yeah he doesn't want me on his
show mhm and he could have been
defensive not defensive at all like I
love you I want to have you on the show
yeah come on that mean and that would be
he saw those
numbers I mean low I'm sure he probably
did beforehand but yeah like have to say
it not who doesn't want cat but he's
always spoken highly of of cat
like yeah I mean cat's just got some
iconic specials that's the thing like
cat I think cat is maybe in his head he
sees himself as like a like a street
dude comic and real for the streets and
blah blah but like I think cat has
crossed over to
mainstream with
standup like only maybe a handful of
other commies that came up in this in
the strictly black circuit in history
like I don't know a white person that
hasn't loved it's Pimping Pimping or
what's the other one hustle everyday
hustle every like Pimp Chronicles
American Hustle it was like mandatory
viewing yeah so I'm just like I wonder
if his perception of his Fame is
skewed maybe he doesn't realize how much
he's actually crossed over how much
white people brown people [__] with him
possibly but he also is justess acting
like a comic because you guys are some
of the most competitive
[__] and sensitive so if you
combine those two things competitiveness
and sensitiveness oh my God yeah and ego
sometimes like that [__] is crazy y so
he's just kind of just talking I think
the way like sometimes Comics might talk
in like a green room or some [__] like
that but he's just doing it publicly
he's just airing it out but he's so
calculated he's so smart he knows what
he doing that's the thing like oh yeah
he absolutely knew yeah right there's a
couple times he chuckled to himself dirt
he's like oh I'm the
greatest he knew this [__] was going to
go crazy you can go to prize.com use the
promo code Schultz SZ you're going to
get 100% deposit match up to
$100 thank about that okay you put in
100 they're match with 100 then you go
get your prize picks on make sure you go
to prize picks.com use that promo code
SCH